[Musique]
le québec est le troisième plus gros
producteur de canneberges au monde et 70
% de la récolte est transformée en jus
est vendue dans plus de 25 pays
nous profitons aujourd'hui des portes
ouvertes dans le cadre des journées de
la culture à radio canada pour faire
goûter justement trois produits à base
de jus de canneberge dans un mélange de
jus un cocktail de 4 berges et du jus
pur de canneberges place à la
dégustation des amateurs de jus de
canneberge
avez vous déjà remarqué qu est-ce qui
avait décrit sur les bouteilles que vous
achetez en fait la canneberge étonne aux
petits fruits
chouchou en vie dit il presque aussi
identitaire au québec que le bleuet
sauvage les pourquoi parce qu'on a les
conditions parfaites au québec pour
pouvoir cultiver la canneberge
elle est ici en fait naturellement
depuis probablement depuis toujours
en terme de goût donc on a affaire à
trois univers complètement différent
dans ce que si on est vraiment sur la
canneberge pur donc plus astringente
plus assidus les embauches dans les deux
autres cas on a affaire à des produits
qui sont très sucré on met jamais
laquelle on peut légitiment les trois
gamins les canneberges rsa a pas photo
comme c'est comme trouble est honteux
vous qu'est-ce que l'an passé du rouge
et pas beaucoup c'est le goût de la
canneberge la canneberge a la
particularité ou le petit défaut qu'on
pourrait lui dire d'être très astringent
très acide donc c'est un goût qui nous
fait faire la grimace un peu le sapin
ici s'il joue quand on le prend en frais
ce qui plaît pas à tout le monde
ça c'est du 100% g km vous prendriez sac
à l'occasion pour s'appeler jus de
canneberge peu ça ne doit être que du
jus de canneberge
donc on voit déjà dans sa couleur il est
beaucoup plus rouge beaucoup plus de
danse puis on et ben c'est clairement la
canneberge on sent tout le fruit
l'acidité j'étais rome donc c'est un
produit qui traiterait peu sucré parce
que la canneberge comme fruit et un
fruit qui contient très peu de sucre
naturellement c'est fait pour être
mélangé d'ailleurs le fabricant nous le
suggère sur le devant de la malade de le
mélanger ou mon truc
en fait et d'y aller avec un moitié
moitié moitié au moitié des canneberges
depuis hier et de sirop d'érable
c'est parfait
georges et quel est votre préféré
jamais jean les genres fait voilà
convaincu que si vous trouvez que ça
goûte la canneberge
je trouvais pas ça trop scream ou 26 g
certaines boissons gazeuses celui-là
n'est pas un jus de canneberge mais un
cocktail de canneberges ce que ça veut
dire c'est qu'il a été diluée avec de
l'eau et sucrés côté sucre c'est là où
ça fait plus mal 26 grammes de sucre
partance on voit bien la couleur rouge
la canneberge mais qui est quand même un
peu diluée par rapport au jus pur par
contre au nez on reconnaît clairement
qu'il s'agit d'un jus de canneberge
malgré tout les 2 et 3 mai 2011 c'est
trop c'est vraiment des canneberges mais
du désert
alors on voit très bien ici que le jus
de canneberge a été diluée et mélanger
avec autre chose parce que beaucoup
moins de pigments rouges
et puis on est bon on sait plus trop à
un test à la veille que je pense pas que
personne identifiée qu'il s'agit d'un
jus de canneberge ici ce n'est pas un
aliment miracle ce n'est pas un
médicament mais c'est définitivement une
petite perle qu'on a un courage inouï
nantis dans ce lieu béni ci est le mieux
possible
alors qu'en ont pensé nos joyeux
visiteurs aujourd'hui neuf personnes ont
bien émis le jus de canneberge pure mais
on a encore la dent sucrée ya dix-sept
personnes qui ont préféré le mélange de
jus oasis et 24 ont préféré le cocktail
merci beaucoup à nos guitares
[Musique]